hello out there I'm Chris Kohler and
you're watching be wired Channel today
we are headed over to Smosh games to
talk about the best games of 2014 the 14
best games of 2014 in no particular
order starring joven Shire sohinki
Mari lasercorn and Chris :
number one super smash brothers so much
going on and the smash run was really
fun on the DSU but I think 8-player
smash on the Wii U is just amazing but
in general it seems like definitely
desert devil is alright put it on the
list number two infamous second son I
played it for like an hour and a half
and then I'm like yeah I just never had
the desire to play any further rebug
that's enough you guys three number
three sunset overdrive just going from
point A to point B no matter what it is
you're doing in sunset overdrive is
super super fun it felt like it could
have been last gen was my first
impression my buddy I will nominate it
solely for the teddy bear grenade I
wouldn't say it's at the top of a top
ten
I think that's five votes some
begrudging number four Middle Earth
shadow of Mordor awesome game um the
main complaint about this game it's like
oh it's just Assassin's Creed but it's a
set in middle-earth I'm like that sounds
awesome
that isn't if you would describe that to
me a year before it came out I feel like
make that game alright we all seem
pretty excited about shadow of Mordor
here's Hobbes or five number five
nidhogg fences the the artworks simple
it was on Steam is really fun a lot of
fun we did a video where we all play
this game and joven got crushed horribly
yeah and so he is now biased against the
game he hates it because we stomped all
over his face bias possibly but still a
valid vote against it I want it on the
list yeah Wow yeah three number six
titanfall it was one of the coolest
mixtures we've seen so far of normal
first-person shooter combat with mechs I
am terrible at first-person shooters
titanfall always made me feel like I was
winning right because when you blue
imagine tight fallin and say you lose
you're horrible it says you have to get
out escape into the chopper right I want
it on the all football I'll go more or
less number seven Dragon Age Inquisition
I think one of the first games to really
push the next-gen consoles to show what
they're capable of the entire world of
Dragon Age 2 is the size of one city by
oh we're doing a fanservice game again
is bringing Bioware back to where it
used to be a five based purely on try on
your expert opinion act number eight
jazzpunk was published by Adult Swim it
is indescribably hilarious I cannot find
the words it's interesting I would say
yay for indie games put it on the list
I'd like I you know I understand if it
goes away later but I just like on the
chalkboard yes number nine Mario Kart 8
it ruins friendships and it's a lot of
fun man I didn't need to say anything
else like it was amazing I don't even
know if they knew what they were doing
but they deliberately destroyed that oh
yeah yeah that was bad but on the list I
say yes number 10 South Park stick of
truth' got everything you love about
watching a South Park episode it looks
exactly like a sub yeah it's amazing and
it's funny all the way throughout I
would put it on the list solely for the
invention of dire Bay's yeah they're
like regular bears
it's only my diet you can follow the
canada segment where the canada is an
8-bit is you know dragon heart aflame
it's great to see TV shows making great
video games
alright so South Park's ticket drew can
go up there number eleven Octodad
dadliest catch this must happen you are
playing an octopus who is pretending to
be a human by putting on a suit this
fools everyone although that was on my
tongue oh alright Octodad goes up there
number 12
smite such a great take on MOBA with
because instead of you know looking at
everything from the top down you're
there you're in it that was a completely
different view it made me feel like I
was more involved in the game I enjoyed
it so
my number 13 hearthstone probably the
most popular card game even those
digital other than Magic the Gathering
it's like magic and it deals with the
one issue I have with magic is that I
hate having to have an actual physical
collection of magic cards because I'm
afraid I'm going to lose them or Bend
him with her soon it's great it's like
they're all there they'll be in mint
condition forever because they're
digital it's not easy to make a card
game that works this well and because of
that it does deserve its spot alright
put it up there
number 14 captain toad treasure tracker
toad Mario's long-suffering companion
has never had his own video game so for
that reason captain toad treasure
tracker they did a good job like you
said taking something that fans loved
and turned it into again honorable
mentions Donkey Kong Country tropical
freeze all I see is the Metroid Prime
game that I didn't get attack on Titan
tribute game very hard to get the hang
of but once you do it's insanely fun
Final Fantasy 6 best game of 1994 yeah
plants vs. zombies garden warfare it was
a fun unique third-person shooter and
kept things fun The Last of Us
remastered beautiful and I think it's
actually a unique take on a zombie story
full of funk on beauty and destiny I
can't stop playing it and there is
something to say about that the hunter
hmm beautiful best game of 2015 after
like maybe two more sets of DLC more
stages more guns more reasons to keep
playing well thank you guys very much
for being here with us you really
appreciate it thank you for watching
subscribe to the wired channel for more
and hey why not subscribe to the Smosh
games channel while you're at it how
about that you've heard from our panel
of experts now we want to know what is
your pick for the best game of 2014
let us know right down there in the
comments and hey you subscribe to the
wired Channel while you're at it to be
sure